those were the days back when Germans
and Americans still appreciated each
other but something's changed between
the u.s. and it's one time model pupil
Germany the ease is gone and so is the
trust i think German American relations
are at the lowest point they've ever
been a transatlantic partnership does
not mean that one partner does what it
wants while the other looks on it showed
this relationship now it will stay
important selectively but it will no
longer be the centerpiece of either
American foreign policy or international
relations the reason for the discontent
is that the u.s. is monitoring global
data traffic also in Germany and it's
highly likely that includes the
Chancellor's communications for several
months German officials have been trying
to find out exactly what information the
u.s. is gathering and extract a promise
that Washington will stop doing it in
the future so far that's been
dramatically unsuccessful disc on each
side the u.s. cannot act like a hegemon
throwing around its economic and
military might like it did during the
Cold War it doesn't work that way a
genuine partnership can only exist on an
equal footing to those in the former
West Germany after the Second World War
America was Victor protector and role
model and eventually a lie and even if
the German public criticizes US policies
the political and business elite have
always stood alongside the United States
but the NSA affair has changed that
stubbornness in on some folk there's
great uncertainty among the public here
in Germany and the political class is
dissatisfied with the silence coming out
of Washington against that background
people see the situation very
differently today including
transatlantic relations than they did 20
years ago for Swansea Cardiff
agribusiness mr. president thank you for
having us Germany's displeasure has been
felt in the u.s. a clear sign of that
came when President Barack Obama gave an
exclusive interview on German
TV in which he admitted making mistakes
it was a conciliatory gesture but little
more I don't need and I don't want to
harm that relationship by surveillance
mechanisms that somehow would impede the
kind of communication and trust that we
have and so what I can say is as long as
I'm president the United States the
Chancellor of Germany will not have to
worry about this but the u.s. still
needs to gather data he said the NSA
affair has highlighted that the u.s.
certainly values Germany as an ally but
won't change its political course when
it comes to global data monitoring or
military missions and besides Americans
don't really understand what all the
fuss is about there's been this
disagreement or mini crisis if you will
over the NSA experience okay so let's
move beyond that and let's have a
broader and deeper conversation not just
bilaterally but let's have a broader and
deeper conversation again about what
ought to be the rules for the globe
Richard Haass was an adviser to the
first president george bush and later to
his son today he heads america's most
influential foreign policy think tank he
says the u.s. is looking for allies that
will play along without reservations
americans do not get up in the morning
and say how do we limit Germany's role
the reality is Germans get up in the
morning and limit their own role simply
because of what they're not prepared to
do
the good old days are definitely over
Germany certainly wants to remain at the
United States side but the question
people here are asking is at what price
you